[Music]
no man sky is long-awaited up gay
foundation is here with implemented base
building freighters three different
modes to play and overall quality of
life improvements all this sounds cool
but you might be asking how does this
actually affect the game well here's a
rough layout of foundation and how it
fits into your long-term play
upon loading up your old save even
starting a new one on any mode you'll
notice you have three new field tech
items communication stations safe points
and most importantly the signal booster
which is probably the first thing you'll
want to craft fire it up and scan your
area for points of interest like hot
resource deposits or colonial outposts
for tech whatever you decide don't
forget to delete and salvage that
booster so you don't have to scavenge
for platinum all over again and if that
planet suits you you can wear it forever
search for a habitable base and claim
that rock as your homeworld and now your
base building why doing so leads to side
quests which in turn lead to new tech
you'll start small first you'll need to
craft a construction terminal to which
you'll need to recruit a scientist to
operate it don't worry every space
station will have one and free of charge
fly back home or for convenience you can
use the teleporter located on the other
side of the station hangar once you're
back strike up a convalescent uu line of
quests for tech eventually the
construction specialist will allow you
to build the other three terminals to
which you recruit more specialists at
space stations for instance the weapons
specialist brings on tech for your ship
and multi-tool science brings you tech
for mining in your EXO suit and a
farming specialist for growing plants
keep talking to them and eventually
you'll be able to build items like
beacons to remind you where rare
deposits are and probably most
importantly Auto mining units set and
forget baby ultimately you're going down
that similar path of becoming more
efficient with raking and resources as
you gain new tech because part of your
MO is to get as many units as humanly
possible you're striving to get one of
the new freighters freighters carry
massive amounts of storage with their
ability to hold an insane amount of
cargo space get that 15 million unit
freighter and you're the ultimate trader
rocking the cosmos
and there's your rough basic layout for
new based building progression and no
man sky thanks for watching if you have
a pointers yourself do put them in the
comment section below
you